what's going on everybody welcome to
part 31 of our matplotlib tutorial video
series in this part what we're going to
be talking about is 3d bar charts so 3d
bar charts are probably the most
interesting version of a 3d chart
because it actually gives you the
opportunity to have actually more than
three dimensions now I don't want
anybody to take that as I'm saying you
can actually plot in the fourth
dimension what I'm saying is you can
plot four dimensions or more than three
dimensions I'm not saying you can plot
in the fourth dimension so calm your
calm yourself now anyway coming into
matplotlib or I mean Pat flows have
paint trusty paint the interesting thing
with bar charts is even in a 2d bar
chart you have a starting point and a
height whoops
you have a starting point in a height
that's not much better but you've got
you get the idea and then you also have
a width so you actually have three
dimensions in your typical bar chart now
in a three dimensional bar chart you
actually get to add one more dimension
and that's depth okay so you get to add
that depth dimension and that gives you
four dimensions that you get to actually
plot with a three dimensional bar chart
so that's interesting
so anyways we'll minimize this for now
we'll come back to it don't worry that
won't be the last you see of my painting
so one thing I do want to show before we
move on to the next bar charts is here
this is our old like scatter plot
tutorial and then we've also got this
wire frame that we plotted I just want
to show you that you can plot multiple
3d elements on the same kind of sub
plots so let's do that real quick just a
show and sure enough there you go so
we've got the scatter plots and the
wireframe now of course this is this is
connecting the dots because we use the
same coordinates as you know same XYZ
basically but you could have your little
squiggles going on over here too if you
wanted so anyway just showing you guys
that you can connect the dots or even
have your own or different types you can
throw in a 3d bar chart on the same
chart too I think will refrain from
doing that but you could if you wanted
and maybe we will we'll see let's see
what I decided to do so let's close out
of all this
and let's see well let me just let me
comment out of this comment out this and
we'll keep let's copy this and then
we'll just put it down here I really do
want to like add the bar to this jerk
okay I just wanted to do it it's so
anyway we're gonna call this X 3 y 3 + Z
3 X 3 that can stay the same y 3 you can
say the same and then for Z 3 we're
going to we're gonna use numpy for this
so let me pull this up real quick and
we're gonna use numpy two zeros and so
for those who don't know how this can
work
let's do Python 34 I'm just bringing it
up you can follow along if you want but
it's not necessary import numpy as NP
and then we say x equals NP zeros and
then 10 but this does is it makes an or
X is equal to an array of 10 zeros done
you can also do the same thing with ones
so you can say x equals NP zeros 10 you
could say MP dot ones 10 X now it's 10
once that's all there is to it so moving
that out of the way Z is going to
instead of be this it'll be MP dot 0 s
10 now the reason why we're doing that
is with XYZ I told you I'd bring back
paint there we go encore everyone now
the way that typically the XYZ axes are
gonna work is you'll have like your x
axis Y or Y axes so this will be your x
axis this is your y axis and yours this
is your z axis okay so your z axis is
actually the one that goes up so if Z is
anything other than 0 your bars are
gonna start like here or here or here so
we're not aiming to do that in this
example you could but that's not kind of
what we're hoping for at the moment but
that would be an example of how you
would actually add a 5th dimension would
be the start point of Z right now we're
cheating and we're just we're making it
be a ground
and we're normalizing that across all
bars but you could have another
dimension that allows for that change
anyway moving right along
so x3 y3 z3 we've got that information
now we have to add the depth so we're
gonna have DX dy and DZ and these will
equal something DX will be numpy a dot
ones 10 what this means is like how far
back is that the X gonna go we just want
it to go one Y same thing NP dot ones 10
and then Z Z we want actually to be an
array to 10 so we'll just take this one
copy/paste done now we do a X 1 bar 3d
then we do x3 y3 z3 then we do DX dy DZ
and that should be it so let's save and
run that numpy not defined we need numpy
import numpy as NP try again okay so now
we have our bars pretty cool so one
thing that we can do let's close out of
this I'm gonna sure stop I can't
remember if Styles apply I don't think
they do but let's try import in poor
Matt pluck lib dot style as style or no
from Mapple import stuff I'm dying from
matplotlib import style style that use
let's just do it step 5 35 38 oh we
actually got away with it
interesting ok so you actually can't
apply styles to the 3d plots I had no
idea anyway cool so there you go
so we've plotted those now so so like I
was saying before right here is your
you've got your x-axis your y axis and z
axis is the height so again with the z
axes you can actually see what's
happening here with the height we did
just an array 210 right so we started
off with you know
two three four five six nine ten as our
height but we actually could have also
we've had the Z starting point and the Z
height our Z starting point was that
zero and then we have the height so it's
quite interesting actually because you
can do all kinds of crazy stuff with
these bars so an example here what what
I mean
is these are numpy zeros but we could
change this to be too fine let's just
I'm just gonna throw some stuff in here
you can copy me or do your round doesn't
matter
so now quite interesting they're like
floating in the air basically and that's
what I mean because you can actually you
can do a lot of really interesting
things with that because you're allowed
to have quite a few dimensions that are
normally not capable of being plotted
too easily on a chart so it's kind of
neat now the last thing is let's try
since all of our data is in the same
issue ange let me let's try to let's
plot all of these and just see what
happens
I have too much fun yes then bars are
kind of in the way but that's okay yeah
so we just kind of threw everything
together not exactly the best looking
graph but it's a graph nonetheless so
anyway let's go ahead and comment those
out yeah all right uh-huh that's that
with this tutorial let me make sure that
renders us a bar chart again yes and
then I want this to be was this the one
that we did not yeah so I'm PI zeros 10
and we don't really need any of this
stuff it's coming those out see we run
that cool okay
that's reasonable for me to post on the
blog alright so anyways that is a 3d bar
charts tutorial in the next tutorial
we'll talk about is a more complex
version of a wireframe and really just
wrap up this this series so anyway stay
tuned for that
and thanks for watching